bonsoir le journal sur tv fil 78 du
lundi au vendredi dès 18h et dans
l'actualité locale de ce mercredi 17
décembre trois jours de débats autour du
budget et de la région ile de france un
débat forcément où le un an des
prochaines élections
jean paul huchon socialiste fortement
attaquées par son opposition menée par
l'ump valérie pécresse autres scrutins
les élections départementales la gauche
peut-elle réussir l'union cela semble
plutôt mal engagée avec les premières
annonces de candidatures du parti
socialiste le point tout à l'heure avec
olivier parent et jacquot secrétaire
départemental d'europe écologie les
verts il est l'invité du journal et puis
la pole dance quitte les clubs de strip
tease le grand public en raffole il est
de plus en plus facile de trouver des
associations proposant des cours
découverte de la discipline à la fin de
cette édition
najat vallaud-belkacem la ministre de
l'éducation a dévoilé ce midi
aujourd'hui les collèges qui obtiennent
le statut de rêve pour réseau
d'éducation prioritaire cette
appellation remplacent les zones
d'éducation prioritaires les zep à saint
quentin 3 collèges sont ainsi concernés
gustave courbet le village et youri
gagarine situer donc à trappes
on va écouter tout de suite bertrand
mesure le secrétaire départemental
snuipp-75 8 il regrette que cette
décision ne concerne pas la globalité du
cursus scolaire des élèves ont par des
réseaux d'éducation prioritaire donc des
écoles élémentaires et maternelles qui
alimentent ces réseaux or on se retrouve
en particulier dans les yvelines avec un
certain nombre d'écoles qui se retrouve
isolé parce que pour leur malheur elle
alimente un collège où existe une vraie
mixité sociale
pour autant la situation de ces écoles
quand lé prix du point de vue de la
situation de l'école est une situation
particulièrement dégradé je vais vous
donner un exemple c'est celui du bois de
l'étang la verrière qu'on ne peut pas
qualifier de situations favorables et
qui pour autant va sortir l'éducation
prioritaire au motif que les élèves du
bois de l'étang vont à philippe de
champaigne aux minimes saint-denis
éducation toujours il aura passé cinq
ans à la tête de l'académie des yvelines
jean michel coignard quitte son poste le
directeur académique prend en charge dès
cette fin d'année une mission de trois
ans auprès du ministère de l'éducation
nationale
à 54 ans il cède sa place à serge
clément l'ancien directeur académique de
la loire jean michel coignard qui aura
eu entre autres la lourde tâche
d'accompagner la mise en place des
nouveaux rythmes scolaires invités
politiques et de ce 17 décembre olivier
paréja bonsoir vous êtes co secrétaire
départemental d'europe écologie les
verts élections départementales fin mars
à travers toute la france élection
particulière pour la première fois il
faudra renouveler l'ensemble des
conseillers généraux et pour la première
fois il faudra élire des binômes femmes
hommes
pour respecter bien évidemment la parité
avant de vous faire réagir sur ces
changements tout de même votre sentiment
sur un sondage qui date du 16 décembre
est dit hier un sondage qui révèle 28%
d'intentions de vote pour le front
national 25 % pour l'ump 17 % pour le ps
europe ecologie les verts à 7% à égalité
avec lui dit et derrière le front de
gauche 7%
c'est un chiffre au niveau national et
c'est un sondage à quelques mois de
l'échéance ça vous semble acceptable 7%
nécessairement que ça fait pas plaisir
de savoir que les sondages donnent 7%
mais c'est aussi le temps de la campagne
qui nous permettra peut être d'arriver à
expliquer notre programme a réexpliqué
notre différence par rapport à ce qui se
passe par exemple aujourd'hui au
gouvernement on va vous parler cette
différence c'est à dire que l'union
l'union que j'évoquais mon titre ce
n'est pas du tout à l'ordre du jour pour
l'ensemble des forces de gauche et des
listes communes dans les yvelines avec
le parti socialiste europe écologie ça
n'existe pas précisé si on dit que il va
y avoir très peu de votants à cette
élection à dire qu'il va y avoir une
abstention assez importante
les gens sont déçus par la politique du
gouvernement donc nécessairement il faut
être clair il faut un message clair à
savoir si on soutient ou on ne soutient
pas la politique actuelle du
gouvernement
nous on a envie de construire et c'est
pour ça qu'on a lancé il ya quinze jours
l'appel au rassemblement donc un large
appel sur nos valeurs pour essayer de le
re 2 de fédérer ça peut être des
collectifs ça peut être des citoyens ça
peut être aussi des mouvements
politiques n'est pas des socialistes en
tout cas mais il ya l'histoire pente
mais j'ai oui enfin chacun ce qu'il veut
mais l'idée c'est quand même d'avoir un
message clair autour de nos valeurs donc
nécessairement le message c'est pas nous
sommes contre quelque chose le message
c'est de dire on peut faire autre chose
dans les yvelines
la droite dans les yvelines fait depuis
des années une politique très libéral
avec un peu de sou de poudrage de social
par ci par là et c'est contre cette
politique qu'on voudrait vraiment
inscrire les yvelines dans dans les
yvelines du 21e siècle quelque chose qui
soit beaucoup plus soutenable en termes
de développement économique et donc on a
un programme alternatif a proposé à
construire avec ce rassemblement qu'on
veut qu'on veut créer mais on l'a vu
quelques fois sur certains scrutins il y
avait une division au niveau national
entre le parti socialiste et ses alliés
de gauche mais au niveau local
quelquefois on pouvait voir naître un
désaccord parce que vous vous retrouviez
sur une politique commune
là ce n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui avec
le parti socialiste dans le département
des yvelines
il n'y a aucun point commun avec europe
ecologie les verts aucun terrain
d'entente pour 7 pour ce scrutin
départemental nécessairement il doit y
avoir un certain nombre de points
communs
simplement on a appelé au rassemblement
autour de nos valeurs à nous qui sont
des valeurs écologistes qui sont des
valeurs de solidarité
après bienvenue à tous ceux qui veulent
qui veulent rejoindre notre
rassemblement mais sur nos valeurs
aujourd'hui c'est sur nos valeurs n'est
pas sûr voilà l'idée ce n'est pas de
faire un rassemblement pour faire un
rassemblement je pense que c'est ce que
je disais au début une des causes de
l'abstention c'est que le message n'est
pas clair
donc à un moment il faut revenir aux
fondamentaux vraiment ce qui fait la
différence qui fait l'intérêt de voter
écologistes de voter ce sur un programme
social solidaire pour les yvelines et
quitte à perdre dès le premier tour en
panne présent sur le second tour pour
les forces de gauche mais validé ce qui
la division de la gauche c'est souvent
comme ça à peu de participation division
de la gauche l'ump le front national qui
se retrouve au second tour leur
naissance de gauche éliminée c'est
évident qu'un seul objectif que nous
avons c'est de d'éviter que 21 cantons
soit à droite ou au front national
fin mars ça c'est évident est la
meilleure façon de le faire c'est
d'avoir un message clair et l'abstention
est probablement
le premier parti de france comme on dit
est donc l'enjeu c'est d'arriver à
exprimer qu on a une différence
on a un vrai programme quelque chose qui
peut faire que les gens reviennent voter
donc dû me caractérise ce vrai programme
que vous avancez justement la valeur les
valeurs fortes du programme qui sera
présenté par europe écologie si on
reprend ce par exemple et les
compétences du département
il ya des compétences sur les transports
aujourd'hui on a plus de 1600 km de
routes départementales
est-ce qu'il n'est pas temps de penser à
la continuité des liaisons cycliste est
ce qu'il faudrait pas mettre encore plus
d'énergie sur les transports en commun
en relation avec la région ile de france
on peut parler aussi de de l'aménagement
urbain aujourd'hui les yvelinois les
élus guînoise passent plus de deux
heures dans les transports
chaque jour il ya vraiment une autre
façon de gérer l'aménagement du
territoire de rapprocher les lieux de
vie le lieu de travail
il ya eu un développement qui peut être
beaucoup plus économe des terres
agricoles par exemple donc et et
développer plutôt des petites et des
moyennes entreprises développer de
l'économie sociale et solidaire
développer des emplois locaux donc il ya
vraiment moyen d'avoir une politique
très différente de celle que mène le
conseil général ou celle que soutient le
conseil général aujourd'hui et il faut
absolument que l'on puisse exprimer
cette différence est que l'on puisse
exprimer ce programme et le présenter
aux électeurs alors cette différence
était lisible dans l'opinion publique
notre question du jour quelle image
avez-vous d'europe écologie et les verts
voici vos réponses vous allez gens ne
vont donc pas écouté avec attention les
réponses insignifiante d'un niveau assez
faible mais par rapport à tous les
autres partis c'est exactement la même
chose
une image neutre je vote pas pour eux
mais mais pourquoi pas je le vois quand
un parti j'ai bonne idée qui va au bout
de ses convictions la plupart du temps
mais qu'elles quand même beaucoup de mal
à s'imposer dans le paysage politique
français
on leur fait beaucoup de promesses aussi
et que on les laisse pas toujours
exprimé leur point de vue on la leur
laisse pas toujours leur chance un de
mettre en oeuvre certaines propositions
qui seraient vraiment pas compliqué à
mettre en oeuvre
moi je pense est un parti utile qui met
fille doit s'intégrer en fait à
l'ensemble des autres des autres partis
je pense que c'est pas un parti unique
c'est un parti qui doit être
complémentaire de dinde autre parti un
parti complémentaires ça va peut-être un
petit peu à contre sens de ce que vous
disiez quand vous disiez qu'il faut
justement les idées d'europe écologie
sont entendus dans l'opinion publique
et là on dit c'est un parti
complémentaires il faudrait que ça se
retrouve dans le programme des autres ah
non enfin on peut l'entendre
différemment comment vous l'avez prendre
le partie complémentaire ça peut être
que c'est peut-être un parti qui va
apporter quelque chose dans le cadre
d'un regroupement et apporter sa pierre
à la construction d'un projet qui peut
être plus large qui peut être un projet
alternatif de gauche donc il ya une
discussion aujourd'hui en tout cas pas
avec le parti socialiste on a compris
qu'il y avait des divergences avec les
autres forces de gauche le front de
gauche le parti communiste vous discuté
sur des listes communes
donc le fonctionnement d'europe écologie
les verts est d'avoir défini une
stratégie départementale et ensuite
canton par canton
les les adhérents d'europe écologie les
verts les sympathisants en essayant de
de discuter avec les collectifs qui
existe avec les personnes qui sont
engagés dans la vie associative qui ont
particulièrement participer à des luttes
contre des projets inutiles
je prendrai par exemple on en a parlé il
ya quelques temps de la colline de la
revanche et de la piste ski artificielle
bombe à tous ces gens qui se sont
regroupés autour de valeurs qui sont
proches de l'écologie eh bien on est
ouverts à travailler avec eux et a co
construire un projet et des candidatures
pour les départementales et bien sûr ça
s'ouvre aussi à des mouvements
politiques qui peuvent être
effectivement le parti de gauche le
parti communiste qui peuvent être
nouvelle donne s'est ouvert et ce sera
discuté canton par canton de façon à
trouver les personnes qui peuvent le
mieux portée d i d idées de solidarité
les îles écologique mais il y aura des
listes soutenues par europe ecologie les
verts donc 21 cantons dans les 21
cantons du département
ah oui c'est le problème n'est pas un
problème de personne c'est à dire on
aurait très bien pu partir et m 21 x 4
puisqu'il faut utiliser
voilà deux suppléants donc on aurait pu
mettre 21 x 4 personnes sur tous les
cantons des yvelines ça n'a pas été
notre choix mais c'est pas un problème
de nombreuses personnes
c'est vraiment une volonté d'ouverture
une volonté d'essayer de construire une
alternative à gauche
cette idée de binômes justement c'est
une bonne idée d'avoir présenté un
canton je pense qu'europe écologie les
verts a toujours défendu la parité
donc c'est quelque chose qui fera que
aujourd'hui on a un conseil
départemental qui a à peu près le même
nombre de conseillers que l'on attendait
qui aiderait à 40 ça va être à peu près
ça va être à peu près la même chose et
aujourd'hui il ya quatre ou cinq femmes
c'est absolument ridicule comme
représentation donc on arrive par
construction à la parité c'est quelque
chose qui va tout à fait dans le bon
sens les noms seront les candidats sont
connus quand elle est le calendrier dans
la mesure où on est dans une une
construction canton par canton
nécessairement le calendrier est pas
avec une date fixe pour tout le monde
donc on est en train d'avancer
probablement début janvier on sera
capable d'annoncer les d'aider les
quadrino enfin les personnes canton par
canton qui ceux qui se présenteront
on va passer avoir de nom ce soir que
vous n'avez pas donné de nom puisque
l'état ne peut pas leur dire voilà on va
même se dire qu'on est en train
d'appeler au rassemblement et dire on a
déjà tout notre liste non nécessairement
on est en train de construire donc des
noms circulent bien entendu mais pour
l'instant ccc ouvert et justement dans
un mouvement le plus participatif
possible
l'ump qui souhaite réaliser le grand
chelem conservez donc ce conseil général
et même accroître son emprise sur le
conseil général le front national qui
annonce aussi qu'il présentait des des
candidats partout et qui pourrait
réaliser un bon score si on en croit les
estimations ne serait ce qu'au niveau
national
est ce que ça vous inquiète ou pas quel
est votre état d'esprit par rapport à
cette situation
c'est sûr que la montée du front
national est quelque chose qui est qui
est d extrêmement inquiétant
par contre le front national monte
généralement en raison de l'abstention
c'est à dire que c'est pas
nécessairement un nombre de votants
supplémentaires c'est simplement c'est
des électeurs motivés et moins il ya de
participation aux élections plus le
fonds national proportionnellement fait
un bon score
votre endurance et de re motiver vos
propres avec exactement des voilà merci
olivier par jade est revenue ce soir sur
ce plateau nous parlons également des
départementales mardi prochain dans le
dos
7-8 politique pour 2014 avec philippe
chevrier le responsable départemental du
front national merci olivier parisien
merci l'agencé nationale pour la
rénovation urbaine l'anru qui vient de
valider la liste de 200 quartier qui
bénéficieront d'un programme de
rénovation l'investissement global et
2,5 milliards d'euros une partie de
cette somme sera utilisée pour quatre
secteurs des yvelines la communauté
d'agglomération de mantes la ville celle
de la boucle de la seine celle de la
scène et vexin et enfin celle de saint
quentin en yvelines plus
particulièrement ici à trappes sur les
merisiers le plan d'action qui couvre
une période se terminant en 2024 premier
critère les difficultés sociales et
urbaines rencontrer les élus régionaux
qui plonge jusqu'à vendredi sur le
budget 2015 des débats qui donne un
avant goût de la prochaine campagne
électorale de décembre prochain qui
pourrait opposer
jean-paul huchon président sortant à
valérie pécresse député ump des yvelines
elles se sont clairement deux visions
qui s'opposent un reportage réalisé pour
tv fil 78 par nos confrères de val
d'oise tv jean paul huchon dévoile les
grandes lignes de son budget le dernier
avant les élections régionales de
décembre 2015 d'un montant de 4,9
milliards d'euros
il sera voté vendredi un budget
franciliens marquée par un maintien des
investissements rock c'est un budget qui
ne lâche rien c'est à dire qui est
présent sur tous les grands secteurs
d'investissement de la région on n'a pas
baissé l'investissement au contraire le
budget augmente on est par ailleurs
maintenant
en mesure de recevoir les fonds
européens et de les gérer donc ça permet
de faire un peu plus un peu mieux en
matière de fonctionnement du est
légèrement en recul
c'est la preuve du sérieux de gestion
qui souligne et des repas la cour des
comptes d'un côté les agences de
notation de l'autre donc j'ai un budget
je dirais qu'ils préparent l'avenir et
qui conforte notre rôle essentiel en
matière d'aménagement du territoire de
transport d'éducation et de formation
pas de suspense l'ump rejettera le
budget de la majorité ps écologistes
radicaux et communistes valérie pécresse
estime que le projet préparé par jean
paul huchon ne répond pas aux attentes
des franciliens en temps de crise la
conseillère régionale des yvelines
propose un contre budget qui ressemble
pour beaucoup au programme qu'elle
pourrait développer lors des prochaines
élections régionales
je crois qu'aujourd'hui on est face à
une situation inédite
le chômage augmente plus vite en ile de
france que partout ailleurs
et aujourd'hui on a un vrai sujet
d'insertion professionnelle des jeunes
donc moi je prendrais tous les crédits
qui sont non prioritaires et je les
affecterait à ses compétences
développement économique aide aux
entreprises en difficulté formation
professionnelle des chômeurs formation
professionnelle des jeunes apprentissage
et c'est ce sera ma priorité est ma
deuxième priorité ce sera de lutter
contre toutes ces fractures
territoriales en ile de france il y a
des quartiers qui sont des quartiers
délaissés jaffe ctte ray une partie des
recettes d'investissement à la dire à la
desserte transport de la grande couronne
et puis au contraire euros pour la
période
les paires et les quartiers périurbains
les élus régionaux vont plancher durant
trois jours sur le budget 2015
des débats qui permettront à jean paul
huchon et valérie pécresse d'affûter
leurs arguments en prévision de la
campagne des prochaines élections de
décembre
on quitte la politique pour la
restauration et cette question votre
plat commandé au restaurant et il al'air
gêne un règlement européen impose à
partir d'aujourd'hui aux professionnels
de faire figurer sur leur carte la
composition détaillée des menus la
mesure n'est pas bien accueilli et ces
derniers évoquent une mise en
application impossible au minimum à des
contraintes supplémentaires yolaine
thorez et william l ces menus du
restaurant les templiers à elancourt
vont bientôt être repassé à la loupe
depuis le 13 décembre une réglementation
européenne impose restaurateurs
l'affichage des 40 principaux allergènes
dans leurs plats la noisette fruits à
coque
ça peut être un produit c'est un produit
allergènes qui sont très allergique à
faire dorénavant pour tous les plats
contenant de la noisette des arachides
du lait ou encore du gluten jean-luc
madec devra s'adapter et le notifier à
ses clients alors la caf et d'aménager
sata soit ce que ce soit une information
claire lisible mais qui amène pas ne
viennent pas polluer le côté vitrine
attractive d'une carte de restaurant
mettre des astérisques le notifier en
bas de la carte
il travaille à des solutions les
restaurateurs ne sont pas tenus
d'inscrire le détail sur les cartes mais
devront avoir une liste disponible des
allergènes à présent dans les plats
déficit depuis plus de 20 ans jean-luc
medac a vu le nombre de clients
allergiques augmenté c'est vrai
de plus en plus de nos compatriotes sont
aujourd'hui soumis à des allergies le
taux a été multiplié par quatre ces dix
dernières années c'est considérable
cette réglementation européenne ne
concerne pas uniquement les
restaurateurs les cantines les épiceries
les traiteurs mais aussi les
boulangeries devons aussi s'y conformer
les contrôles ne se feront pas avant
économie avec le centre commercial des
gatinois plaisir souvenez vous le 8
décembre 2013 il ya tout juste un an
cinq commerces étaient détruits par les
flammes après un départ d'un incendie
dans un restaurant indien 55 pompiers
mobilisés pour maîtriser la situation
est depuis des propriétaires des lieux
qui attendent qu'un second souffle soit
donnée au site pour faire revenir les
clients le point avec florame parfait
et patrick jacques de dixmude un an
après les choses n'ont pas beaucoup
changé au centre commercial des gâtines
les boutiques ravagées par les flammes
sont toujours en ruine les clients n'ont
pas déserté par solidarité mais il
regrette que le lieu soit presque laissé
à l'abandon
on va c'était bien pratique ce subtil ce
petit centre commercial me rendais quand
même bien service puisqu'avec en tout il
y avait donc le casino il y avait de
quoi faire
bon la pharmacienne eu la chance de
continuer donc oui c'est quelque chose
quand même qu'on utilise et qui met un
peu de vie dans le quartier
sinon y'a rien d'autre roh dommage pour
nous personnellement non parce qu'on a
la chance d'avoir une voiture d'être
très mobile mais j'imagine que pour des
gens plus âgés c'est sans doute plus
difficile vincent bayeux a perdu près de
la moitié de son chiffre d'affaires
depuis un an le gérant de la supérette
vont s'est produit dans ce préfabriqué
de 40 m² la procédure dans thiêt les
expertises des assurances ont beaucoup
ralenti le chantier de travaux commencés
normalement fin du mois de décembre
normalement mais bon on attend toujours
qu'on est pour l'instant on est toujours
dans les échos heureusement d'abord pour
dépanner la clientèle tout ça mais on
commence à voir une perte de clientèle
par rapport à sa traîne en longueur
les travaux devaient commencer au début
du mois ils ont été repoussé pour cause
de diagnostic amiante l' attente
interminable à décourager certains
commerçants plus de restaurants ni de
coiffeur seul le boucher charcutier a pu
rapidement se réinstaller en reprenant
les locaux restés intacts de la
boulangerie m'arracher son fond tout
simplement voilà il ya
à huit mois de ça et on a réussi à
ouvrir il ya six mois maintenant ça fait
juste six mois
heureusement pour nous parce que vu
l'état de l'avancée des travaux je
commencerai maintenant mais vous ça va
ça va à part abondé un peu de désertion
de clients avec le peu qu'on aime et
boissons pas se plaindre nous on a
réussi à rebondir c'est l'essentiel
malheureusement commerçants et habitants
attendre l'installation de nouveaux
commerces pour redynamiser le centre
commercial des gâtines pour cela il
faudra attendre juin 2015 la date prévue
pour la livraison de nouveaux bâtiments
à moins d'un nouveau retard culture six
artistes contemporains qui vous invite à
une exposition autour du thème résonance
à la ferme du mousseau l encours
photographies peintures sculptures et
même film évoque la mémoire du corps et
de ses perceptions projeter ses propres
émotions à travers des oeuvres très
diverses présentée à la galerie de la
ferme du mousseau à elancourt vidéo
gravures peintures sculptures la matière
est certes différentes mais le message
est unique
ses oeuvres sont en résonance le titre
de l'exposition
cette année cette exposition a quand
même volonté que différents artistes
répondent à travers leurs oeuvres au
delà de l'aspect résonance des oeuvres
se raisonne aussi bien le mal et le bien
le blanc le gris le noir et le blanc est
donc on est capable de montrer c'est ce
que l'on veut ici que l'art n'exprime
pas seulement que le plaisir et le
bonheur
il exprime aussi des drames il exprime
aussi parce que ça fait partie de la vie
la mort dans ce cadre là nous avons des
artistes qui nous ont proposé des corps
mutilés
mais les corps mutilés comme un espoir
pour la suite c'est six artistes ont été
choisis après une sélection via un jury
une centaine de dossiers a été reçu
cette année parmi eux
thibault la géraud 38 ans son atelier
dans les yvelines
ses grandes toiles colorées raconte des
histoires d'aujourd'hui
l'idée c'est
de l'inspirer 2
d'image de photo reporters qui ont
traité de sujets que ça soit beaucoup
sur le thème de la liberté
donc j'ai beaucoup travaillé sur le
printemps arabe la syrie
je m'inspire de
plutôt de récits et j'essaye à travers
les récits écrits et les photos qui ont
été prises par l'egypte du photo
reporter de compiler en fait sur une
toile
une multitude de sentiments et en fait
l'histoire
l'actualité c'est donc le nerf de la
guerre pour cet artiste et les couleurs
chatoyantes pour mieux masquer la
noirceur des récits sur la couleur je
dirais que c'est venu petit à petit au
départ je croyais avec relativement peu
de couleurs très chromatique de couleurs
complémentaires 3 4 maximum et puis plus
ça va plus les sujets se complexifier
plus j'en rajoute plus le sujet
dramatique plus aujourd'hui je suis
amené à faire des étoiles extrêmement
colorés comme une sorte d' équilibre
entre le sujet de fond et la forme
l'exposition résonances se tient
jusqu'au 21 décembre à la galerie de la
ferme du mousseau à elancourt
et juste après ce journal nouveau numéro
de kiosques avec un 4e nul à toledo
madère dédié à la culture chaque
mercredi 18h30 je vous le disais en
titre la pole dance se détache peu à peu
de son image associée à celle des clubs
de strip strip tease elle s'installe
jean bafouille auprès du grand public
comme une discipline très physique qui
mêle danse et acrobatie il est possible
de prendre des cours à saint quentin en
yvelines reportage en immersion yolaine
thorez elodie mois
le fireman le jimmy nay le bird ou
encore le rockstar les figures
s'enchaînent autour de la barre
verticale
bienvenue dans le monde de la pole dance
pour hélène professeurs ici à versailles
depuis quatre ans il s'agit d'un
véritable sport à part entière
mélange d'acrobaties de danse et de
créativité la pole dance eux se
rapprochent notamment du cirque ou de la
gym mais pas seulement c'est aussi
l'expression corporelle comme la danse
où je peux pas aller jusqu'au théâtre
parce que ces voix là on n'est pas dans
un jeu vraiment mais vient vraiment ça
en fait ça fait ressortir de la
personnalité aussi
et des fois même un peu la gestuelle est
caractère de la personne le cours
commence d'abord par un échauffement et
à peu primordial pour préparer les
muscles les articulations
le bus est d'allonger en fête son but
est d'aller loin devant les danseuses
travail ensuite les figures à la barre
la première qualité pour réussir n'est
pas nécessairement d'être très musclé ou
très souple mais surtout de savoir faire
preuve d'un peu de patience
il ya des choses qu'on aimerait faire
qui sont pas forcément toujours
accessibles les mais en fait si on est
content et si on a envie d'avancer de
tester des choses et comprendre tout le
conseil
on voit les choses surtout dans le bon
ordre avec la bonne technique et c'est
finalement ça fonctionne aucune info de
dernière dans la ramener et là on va
passer le coût des pieds on a pivoté
enroulé et à touba a frappé là où j'aime
bien le côté physique c'est vraiment
très très sportif on se muscle vachement
vite et puis le côté artistique
il ya pas beaucoup de discipline qui
mêle vraiment les deux cas c'est à la
fois plaisant mais en même temps on a
fait tous travailler c'est sympa on est
entre filles on s'amuse beaucoup et puis
voilà c'est un vrai plaisir
on a tendance à vouloir faire les choses
en force alors qu'en réalité lorsqu'on a
compris la technique c'est plus une
force et ça devient quelque chose de
beaucoup plus simple longtemps associé
au monde de la nuit au striptease la
pole dance eux se développe de plus en
plus comme une véritable discipline
sportive
aujourd'hui des championnats de france
sont organisées et des écoles fleuriste
un peu partout l'agent de devant à faire
derrière m on n'en parle plus les gens
sont ouverts et moi on est entendu cette
strip tease tu vas t'on club et ce
trépied c'est moins tabou les femmes
osent le dire que voilà qu'elles ne font
que c'est un vrai sport voilà il nous
faut des fois le maître même en avant
donc petit à petit on part un peu la
coquette comme ça une conquête qui ne
s'arrête pas qu'aux femmes minoritaires
pour le moment certains hommes
commencent aussi à s'y mettre
rendez vous demain jeudi 18 heures pour
une nouvelle édition du journal très
bonne soirée sur téléfilm